اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى اخبار الساعه من
العربيه وهذه هي العناوين
بايدن يهدئ الاسواق بعد تعهده بمحاسبه
الماسونين عن ازمه البنوك واوروبا مطمئنه
الى حين
البنتاجون مليار دولار لشراء ذخيره
واوروبا تزيد انتاجا
وزياره الى موسكو يعقبها لقاء مع الرئيس
الصيني يستكمل مساعيه لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه واشنطن ترحب
وعلى الجانب الاخرى
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاخبار الساعه من
العربيه بعد تطمينات بيض افتتحت الاسم
الامريكيه على تراجع بسيط في اول جلسه لها
بعد انهيار بنك ثم عادت الى تصحيح وضعها
تدريجيا فيما هوى سهم البنك فيرست
ريبابليك الامريكي عند الافتتاح بنحو 67%
وتراجع ايضا مؤشر الاسهم الامريكيه
6.00 في مطلع افتتاح
[موسيقى]
اليوم وجهت الاداره بالتحرك سريعا لاحتواء
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي بامكان
المودعين الوصول الى اموالهم بدون عوائق
المستثمرون الذين يخاطرون بودائع
الامريكيين ستتم محاسبتهم ولن تكون هناك
حمايه لاصحاب قرارات المخاطر التي ادت
لهذه الازمه ولن نسمح بتكرار اخفاقات
البنوك وسنعمل على حمايه الشركات الناشئه
اريد التاكيد على ان دافعي الضرائب لن
يتحملوا اي خسائر بسبب ازمه البنوك
سؤال الساعه لماذا انهار بنك سيليكون فالي
الذي طالما حاضيه بثقه عملائه القصه قبل
نحو اسبوع اعلن البنك بيع عدد من الاوراق
الماليه بسعر يؤدي للخساره ما خلق حاله من
الفزع بين شركه اداره رؤوس الاموال التي
نصحت الشركات بسحب اموالها فورا العديد من
شركات التكنولوجيا على مدى عقود استخدمت
هذا البنك للاحتفاظ بالنقب ما ادى الى
تدفق الودائع لكن مع استثمار البنك جزءا
كبيرا من الودائع بدات الازمه الماليه
تحدث ليبدا العد التنازلي للبنك في فقدان
قيمه السندات خصوصا بعد ان بدا الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي رفع اسعار الفائده بسرعه
لمكافحه او مواجهه التضخم
زاد حينما قرر العملاء سحب مبالغ من
ودائعهم ما اجبر البنك على بيع بعض
السندات بخسائر لتوفير السيول اللازمه في
الثامن من مارس بدا العد التنازلي عندما
اعلن البنك عن زياده راس المال بقيمه ما
يقرب من 2 مليار دولار لينتهي الامر بعد
يومين بانهيار البنك تماما الذي بلغ راس
ماله 200 مليار دولار وهو ما يمثل اكبر
فشل مصرفي في الولايات المتحده منذ الازمه
الماليه العالميه في 2008
هناك تطورات اخيره تهم بعض البنوك التي
اراقبها بعنايه شديده وعندما تتعرض البنوك
لخسائر ماليه يجب ان يكون ذلك مصدر قلق
سيليكون بالي مجله نظام التامين الفيدرالي
يغطي ودائع تصل الى 250 الف دولار ويحمي
جميع الاموال النقديه لمعظم الافراد في
حساب المصرفي حجم المدخرات زاد من 44
مليار دولار نهايه 2017 الى 189 مليار
دولار في نهايه 2021
نمو القروض من 23 مليارا الى 66 مليار
دولار وجود ودائع اكبر بكثير من القروض
استثمار 128 مليار دولار نهايه 2021
معظمها في سندات الرهن العقاري وسندات
الخزانه الانهي ار له تداعيات عالميه
بينها سوق العملات المشفره وتاثير سلبي
على شركات التقنيه او الناشئه صحيفه
الجارديان العديد من الشركات والافراد قد
يخسرون اكثر من نصف ودائعهم
اما مفاوض الاقتصاد بالاتحاد الاوروبي
فقال ان انهيار بنك سيليكون بالي في
الولايات المتحده لا يشكل تهديدا خطيرا
لاوروبا وقال المفاوض الاوروبيه ان احتمال
حدوث تاثير غير مباشر امر يجب مراقبته لكن
في الوقت الحالي لا يعتبر ذلك مخاطره
كبيره وقال ان تاثير انهيار بنك على
الاسواق العالميه كان متوقعا لكنه استبعد
انتقال للعدوى الى اوروبا
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من الرياض عادل افيوني وزير
الدوله اللبنانيه السابق للشؤون الاستثمار
وتكنولوجيا والخبير المصرفيه مرحبا بك
معالي الوزير بايدن اليوم طمانه اصحاب
الودائع هل كل اصحاب الودائع يجب ان
يطمئنوا خاصه تلك الودائع الغير مؤمنه
وماذا عن حمله الاسهم الذين الان هم يعني
لا احد يقدم لهم الدعم
[موسيقى]
بصوره عامه لانه
الاسواق لا تتحمل اليوم في هذه الظروف
هجمه على البنوك او ضربه مصرفيه او صدمه
ولذلك تحاول السلطات تدارك اي انعكاسات
سلبيه لانهيار ما الذي يضمن عدم
انتقال اسماء
الى في رفع اسعار الفائده
اول شيء طبعا من المتوقع بهيك ظرف ومع
الصدمه التي التي خلقتها خلقها او مفاجاه
لخلقتها هذا الانهيار المفاجئ لمصرف يعني
بيسوى تقريبا 200 مليون مليار دولار من
الاصول يعني مصرف السادس عشر في الولايات
المتحده من المتوقع ان تخفف يخفف
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي الامريكي من وتيره
ارتفاع الفوائد او يمكن حتى يجمدها لانه
ما في شك انه ارتفاع الفوائد بهذه الوتيره
السريعه في عام 2022
ادى خلق يعني صدمه على السوق وانعكاساته
بدات بالظهور اليوم بمثل ما شفنا بهذا
المصرف ولكنها تظهر كذلك في سوق العمل في
الاقتصاد يعني الاقتصاد لا يتحمل صدمه
ارتفاع بالفوائد بهذه الوتيره السريعه حتى
اذا كان العذر هو محاربه التضخم ولكن هناك
انعكاسات اخرى منها انعكاسات على القطاع
المصرفي مثل ما عم نشوف
جدير بالذكر انه يعني هذا المصرف الذي
انهار الاسبوع الماضي سيليكون غالبال لم
تكن استثماراته في قروض خطيره او في ادوات
معقده التي تستثمر ما ذكرتي تقريبا 100
مليار دولار في سندات خزينه امريكيه وفي
سندات بسيطه جدا ولم يكن هناك مخاطر من
ناحيه التاثير انهيار هذا البنك على قطاع
تكنولوجيا تحديدا باعتباره كان وثيق الصله
بهذا البنك
نعم هذا طبعا له تاثير هلا النتيجه
الاوليه
للاجراءات التي اتخذتها السلطات ان
المذيعين اي الشركات التكنولوجيا لانه
اغلبيه مدعين هذا المصرف هي شركات
تكنولوجيا المذيعين لن يتاثروا اذا لا
خسائر من وراء انهيار هذا المصرف على
المذيعين او على شركات التكنولوجيا
الكثيره التي كانت تتعامل مع المصرف ولكن
الانعكاسات المتوسطه المدى او الطويله
المدى هي انه هذا المصرف كان من ابرز
الممولين لقطاع التكنولوجيا ولذلك يعني هو
كان يلعب دور مهم في تمويل ونمو قطاع
التكنولوجيا وهي بذلك تفقد شريك اساسي منذ
الثمانينات في دعمها وهذا
المشاهد العادي الذي يستمع الينا منذ ايام
على هذه الازمه الى اي مدى يمكن ان تؤثر
اثر مباشر فيما يتعلق بالاسعار او التضخم
في اسعار الخدمات هل يمكن ان يتاثر
المشاهد العادي الانسان العادي الذي لا
يستثمر اموالا وليس له علاقه بالامر
باعتبار ان هذه ازمه يمكن ان تكون عالميه
لا اعتقد اعتقد انه بالوقت الحالي يعني
الاجراءات التي اتخذتها السلطات هي تحد من
تاثير هذه الازمه بالنهايه هذا مصرف متوسط
الحجم لا علاقات عالميه له او لا تواصل مع
مصارف عالميه اذا ما في اي سبب انهيار هذا
المصرف خاصه بعد الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
ان يكون لها تداعيات على الاقتصاد العالمي
او على
كل هذه الازاحه الثقه اساسيه ولذلك اي
تدابير تحول دون اي هجمه على المصارف
وتعزز من الثقه هي تدابير اساسيه للمحافظه
على الاستقرار بالاسواق ومنها برايي هو
الاستقرار في اسعار الفوائد في هذه الفتره
بالتحديد نعم
[موسيقى]
مع الازمه التي خلفها انهيار بنك سيليكون
فالي اعلن النائب الاول لوزير الدفاع
الامريكيه كابتن هيكس انا واشنطن فقط 30
مليار دولار و600 مليون على شراء الذخيره
فقط في السنه الماليه المقبله واوضح هيك
خلال المؤتمر الصحفي في البنتاجون ان
عمليه الشراء تتم في السنه الماليه 20/24
وهو ما يزيد بنسبه 12 تقريبا عن السنه
الماليه عشرين 23 ايضا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه البينتاجون انها ستشتري 24
صاروخه فرط صوتي خلال العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
ولدينا في اخبار الساعه على شاشه العربيه
الخلافات تتسع بين قضى طالبان افغانستان
وقبل ان نظهر الان هذه صور مباشره
لاجتماعي الرئيس بايدن مع رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ورئيس الوزراء الاسترالي في
اطار الصفقه التي يتم التحالف بشانها في
اطار اتفاق اوكس لتبادل الغواصات النوويه
وهي صفقه حظيه بدجه عالميه كبيره ومخاوف
متزايده لدى الصين
هذا الاتفاق الذي شكل مفاجاه لحلفاء
الولايات المتحده وليس فقط لاعضائها او
لاعدائها هناك تعويل كبير على هذه الصفقه
والى اي مدى يمكن ان يقود هذا التحالف
الجديد الامريكيه البريطانيه الاسترالي
المخاوف الكبيره خاصه في مواجهه الصين
[موسيقى]
نواصل اخبار الساعه من العربيه يبدو ان
التقدم الروسي في حمله للسلاح على مدينه
بخموت الواقعه بشكل اوكرانيا قد تعثر وفقا
لما ذكرته احدى المؤسسات البحثيه الرائده
في تقييم اطول معركه بريه في الحرب معهد
دراسه الحرب ومقره في واشنطن افاد بانه لا
يوجد تقدم مؤكد للقوات الروسيه في ضخمه
وان قوات الروسيه وصلت شن هجمات بريه في
المدينه لكن لا دليل حتى اللحظه على انها
تمكنت بالفعل من احراز اي تقدم وياتي
تقليل معهد دراسه الحرب بعد رواج مزاعمه
عن تقدم الروسي في وقت سابق هذا الاسبوع
وفيما تستمر المعارك العنيفه في مدينه
بحموتشو اوكرانيا اقر قائد القوات البريه
ان الاوضاع في المدينه صعبه جدا مجددا في
الوقت عينه على ان قوته تصدت لكل
المحاولات الروسيه للاستيلاء على ضخموت
عبر المدفعيه والدبابات والقوى الناريه
الاخرى في المقابل لاعلن الكريميلين على
لساني الناطق باسمه انه لا يمكن تحقيق
اهداف روسيا في الاراضي الاوكرانيه الا
بالعمل العسكري وان المسارى السلمي للوضع
في اوكرانيا مستبعد حاليا
ومع دخول الحرب عامها الثاني كشف وزير
داخليه الاوكراني كان الصواريخ والمدفعيه
الروسيه دمرت اكثر من 152 الف مبنى سكني
منذ بدء الحرب على اوكرانيا وان موسكو
نفذت اكثر من 40 الف هجوم وضربه على
البنيه التحتيه المدنيه الاوكرانيه وفقا
لما نقلته وكاله كما سجلت اوكرانيا اكثر
من 66 الف دعوه جنائيه بشان جرائم مزعومه
ارتكبتها القوات الروسيه وفي سياق متصل
تعهدت الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
بتكثيف تطبيق العقوبات على روسيا وزياده
خلق الامدادات وتكنولوجيا الموجهه لجيشها
وتتسرع عمليات التدريب القوات الاوكرانيه
في عدد من البلدان الاوروبيه كبولندا
المانيا اسبانيا على دبابات لوغارت 2
الالمانيه ويامل الغرب ان تغير الدبابات
مجرى المعارك في عدد من الجبهات المشعله
في اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر القادمه
يتدربون اثنتي عشره ساعه في اليوم لسته
ايام في الاسبوع يصارعون عدوهم الاول
الوقت يطوعون ثلاثه اشهر من التدريب
الالزامي في خمسه او ثمانيه اسابيع كحد
اقصى ويعيدون بناء جيش قادرا على استعمال
الات الحرب الحديثه فعشرون بالمئه فقط من
الجيش الاوكراني قادر على التعامل مع
الدبابات الحربيه في ساعات الصباح الاولى
يبدا الجنود الاوكران التدريب في مركز سان
جورجو العسكري في زيرا جوزا شرقيه اسبانيا
حوالي 55 جنديا يتدربون على قطع تحاكي
العمل على الدبابات الحقيقيه قبل خروجهم
الى معسكرات التدريب تتطلب دبابه ليو بارد
الواحده طاقما يتكون من اربعه جنود
لتشغيلها بالمقابل فهي تقدم مميزات عده
تجعل قرار ارسال مئات الجنود الاوكران
للتدريب في خضم الحرب قرارا مهما ويعد
مدفع دبابه ليوبارد اثنان من اهم الميزات
الموجوده فيها اذ يمتلك قدره ثبات عاليه
على الاراضي غير المستويه بسرعه 70
كيلومترا مدعوما بنظام تحكم رقمي ميزه
تفتقر لها الدبابات الاوكرانيه التي تعود
لعهد الاتحاد السوفيتي كما ان مقدمه
الدبابه مدعومه بصفائح مضاده للالغام ميزه
اخرى امام الالغام الروسيه الذكيه التي
تقفز من مكانها لاقتناس الدبابات
الاوكرانيه
يظل تحدي الاكبر هو امكانيه توظيف
التدريبات المكثفه التي تلقاها الجنود في
ميدان المعارك المشتعله الذي سيكون الحسم
في رهان الغربي على هذه الدبابات كرم
حناوي العربيه
وفي مشهد نادر دعت مجموعه من الزوجات
والامهات الروسيات الى التوقف عن ارسال
ازواجهن وابنائهن الى القتال دون تدريب او
امدادات كثيره في اشاره الى المعارك
الجاريه في الشرق الاوكراني حيث اكدت
النساء ان ازواجهن واقاربهن اجبروا على
الانضمام الى مجموعه قتاليه على الرغم من
طلقهن تدريبا غير كاف امتد لاربعه ايام
فقط منذ انخراطهم في الجيش في سبتمبر
المنصرم
قالت الحكومه البريطانيه ان مواجهه
التهديد الذي تشكله روسيا على الامن
الاوروبي سيبقى اولويه في سياستها على
المدى القصير والمتوسط حيث اشارت الحكومه
البريطانيه في تقرير شامل حول الامن
والدفاع والسياسه الخارجيه على ضروره
مواصله دعم اوكرانيا حتى تستعيد سيادتها
ومنع روسيا من اكتساب مزايا استراتيجيه من
الحرب حيث اكدت ان احتواء روسيا والحد من
قدراتها ورغباتها في تحويض النظام الدولي
وامن بريطانيا والمنطقه الاوروبيه
الاطلسيه سيكون هدف بريطانيا الدائم
[موسيقى]
وفي تطور جديد كشفت مصادر مطلعه ان رئيس
الصيني شيجي بنجي يعتزم السفر الى العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو للقاء نظيره في اقرب وقت
خلال الاسبوع المقبل وفي كلمه القاها في
ختام الدوره السنويه للبرلمان شدد الرئيس
الصيني شيجي بنك على ضروره تعزيز الامن
القومي وبذل بكين جهودا ملموسه لتعزيز
الانفتاح على مستوى العالم كما اكد رئيس
الصوميه على ان بلاده ستعمل على تعزيز
امنها القومي للحفاظ على استقرارها مشيرا
الى الصين ستمضي قدما في حملتها للتعبئه
وستؤسس جيشا قويا ليحمي انها ومصالحها
الامن هو اساس التنميه والاستقرار هو
الشرط الاساسي للازدهار وعلينا تنفيذ نهج
شامل للامن القومي وتحسين نظام الامن
القومي لدينا وتعزيز قدرتنا على حمايه
الامن القومي وتعزيز اداره السلامه العامه
وكذلك تحسين نظام الحوكمه الاجتماعيه
لضمان نموذج انمائي جديد
يجب علينا المضي قدما في حملتنا للتعبئه
فيما يتعلق بالدفاع الوطني والجيش
وتحويل جيش الصين الى جدار كبير من الصلب
وبعد الكشف عن زياره المتوقعه الى موسكو
كشف الصحيفه نقلا عن مصادر مقربه من رئيس
الصيني جيجي بنك ان الاخير سيجتمع الرئيس
الاوكراني عبر تقنيه الفيديو لاول مره منذ
الحرب في اوكرانيا واشارت ريزونال الى ان
اللقاء سيكون عقب زياره
من المرجح ان يقوم الرئيس الصيني ايضا
بزياره لدول اوروبيه اخرى
ومن ابو ظبي معنا فتيل بدينان المتحدث
باسم سفاره لاوكرانيه في دوله الامارات
مرحبا بك على شاشه العربيه الى اي مدى
هناك قبول في اوكرانيا بتلك الجهود التي
يقوم بها الرئيس الصيني للوساطه لوضع اطار
لهذه الحرب عبر السلم والمفاوضات
مساء الخير يابا الجرام مساء الخير يا
استوديو
عندما نتحدث عن الصين
فلابد ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار عنا هذه
الدوله هي عظم الدائمه في مجلس الامن
للامم المتحده ومن واجباته الرئيسيه
حمايه المبادئ الاساسيه لمثاق الامم
المتحده وفي المقام الاول السياده والسلام
الاقليميه
وامامنا روسيا الدوله المعتادة واوكرانيا
دوله التي تدافع عن نفسها من هذا العدوان
الهمجي
وفي هذه الحاله نتوقع من العضو الدائم في
مجلس الامن اتخاذ خطوات اكثر صرامه يعني
الخطوات صارمه لاستعاده العداله ومراقبه
الدوله المعتاديه محولات وضع علامه
المساواه بين المعتدي وضحيه العدوان غير
مقبوله بالنسبه
في هذا النوع من الصراعات تكون هناك
الحديث دائما عن صيغه الوسطى لا يخرج منها
الجميع رابح لكل شيء ولا خاسر لكل شيء سقف
التنازل الاوكراني من اين يمكن ان يبدا
اذا قررت الاداره الاوكرانيه هذا الامر
بالطبع
لا طبعا
يجب ان ناخذ يعني عندما نتحدث هذا عن
المبادره السنيه فلا بد ان ناخذ في عين
الاعتبار
القرار الجمعيه العامه التي تم اقراره
يعني في 23 من فبراير بالدعم من واحد
بالدعم 141 دوله
يستند هذا القرار الى صيغه السلام
الاوكرانيه التي طرحها الرئيس اوكراني
ويتطلب الانسحاب الفوري للوتر روسيه من
جميع الاعراض الاوكرانيه واستعاده العداله
والصين كودو دعم في المجلس الامن يجب ان
تهتم باستعاده السلام العادل والمستدام
والامن العالمي وهو امر
تعتقدون سيفتي لان محاوله وقف هذه الحرب
ووقف الكثير من الضحايا والمدنيين الذين
يسقطون يوما بعد يوم اليس هدفا يستحق ان
يتم التنازل بشكل ما لي قار او المسار في
هذه المفاوضات
استعاده السلام العادل والمستدام والامن
العالمي غير ممكن دون استعاده الوحده
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ونعلم ان الصين يمكن ان تمارس الضغط
المناسبه على روسيا من اجل تنفيذ قرارات
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده التي تعضو
الى الانسحاب الفوري للقوات الروسيه من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هل تعملون باستفتاء
اممي في مناطقس
ان انتم تقولون انها اراضي اوكرانيه
وروسيا يقولون انها تتبع القوميه الروسيه
هل مساله وجود استفتاء يمكن ان يحل الامر
ام انكم لن تتنازلوا قيد اموله في هذه
النقطه
[موسيقى]
بتزامن مع اعلان كوريا الشماليه اختبار
الصواريخ كروز تطلق من غواصات بدا الجيشان
الكوري الجنوبي والامريكي اكبر مناورات
عسكريه مشتركه بينهما منذ سنوات طويله
وتشمل المناورات محاكاه حاسوبيه اطلق
عليها رضع الحريات 23 والعديد ايضا من
التدريبات الميدانيه المشتركه والتي سميت
مجتمعه باسم رضع المحارب اف تي اكس وقال
الجيشان الكوري الجنوبي والامريكي في وقت
سابق ان المحاكاه الحاسوبيه تهدف لتعزيز
قدرات الدفاع والاستجابه للحلفاء وسط
التهديدات النوويه المتزايده لكوريا
الشماليه والبيئات الامنيه المتغيره
الاخرى كما اضاف ان المناورات الميدانيه
ستعود ايضا لمستوى اكبر مناورات ميدانيه
سابقه والتي اطلق عليها
ونظمت اخر مره في عام 2018
من جهتها قالت كوريا الشماليه ان اطلاق
صاروخ روز من غواصه قباله ساحلها شرقي
اظهر عزمها على الرد وبقوه ساحقه على
المناورات العسكريه المكثفه التي تجريها
واشنطن فيما قال كبير امناء مجلس الوزراء
الياباني ان طوكيو ستبقى متيقظه بعد اطلاق
كوريا الشماليه لصاروخي كروز من غواصه
احتجاجا على المناورات العسكريه المشتركه
بين الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
بحسب تقرير كوريا الشماليه الصاروخ الذي
اطلقوه اظهر قدره على اصابه اهداف على بعد
1500 كم في حال كان ذلك صحيحا فهو تهديد
للسلام والامن في المنطقه لدينا بعض
المخاوف بشان هذا الامر ندرك ان الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه تجريان مناورات
مشتركه اعتبارا من اليوم دور الجيش
الامريكي بما في ذلك الجنود المتمركزون في
اليابان ودول اسيويه مهم لتحقيق السلام
والاستقرار في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
على صفقه لتبادل الاسرى مع الولايات
المتحده فالمتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه
ناصر كنعاني قال ان الجانب الامريكي قبل
باتمام تبادل السجناء في احدى المراحل
بعيدا عن المحادثات الخاصه بالاتفاق
النووي وشدد على ان لدى بلاده اتفاقا
مكتوبا مع واشنطن حول هذا الملف لكنها
تمتنع عن نشر تفاصيله زعما ان بلاده اثبتت
عمليا التزامها وايمانها بدبلوماسيه كحل
لتسويه الخلافات
[موسيقى]
بعد مرور سنه ونصف من حكمها في افغانستان
تواجه حركه طالبان انقسامات وخلافات واضحه
بين مسؤوليها وعلى وجه التحديد بين زعيم
الحركه المناهضه الله ووزير الداخليه سراج
الدين حقاني الذي بات يرفض اي سلطه اضافيه
لقندهار نتابع التفاصيل
في افغانستان خلافات واضحه برزت في الاشهر
الاخيره داخل حركه طالبان لتنذر بانقسامات
بين قندهار وكابل بعد سنه ونصف فقط من
حكمها خلافات اساسها تقسيم المنصب بين
قاده قندهار اين يوجد زعيم الحركه ملهبه
الله وكابول التي يتواجد بها الوزراء
والمسؤولون فزعيم طالبان اليوم لم تعد
لديه ثقه في المسؤولين في كابول الذين
طلبوا باصلاحات داخليه ينادي بها سراج
الدين حقاني الذي يريد تقييد صلاحياته من
ضمن الاصلاحات تشكيل مجلس شورى للحكم لكسر
سيطره الزعيم على القرارات والسماح
للفتيات بالتعليم والعمل والتفاهم مع
الغرب حول النقاط الخلافيه للاعتراف
بحكومه طالبان لكن زعيم الطالبان يؤكد
بانه سيتخذ كل الخطوات التي من شانها
عرقله مسار تشكيل هذا المجلس ومن هذا يريد
تقييد السلطات كبار القاده في كابول الذين
يتخوفون من ان يقوم الزعيم بتعيين رئيس
وزراء اموال له والافضل بالنسبه له قاضي
القضاه الحالي عبد الحكيم حقاني حيث ذكرت
وسائل اعلام افغانيه بان وزير الماليه
هدايه الله بدري قدم استقالته بعد خلافات
مع زعيم الحركه على اثر ذلك ذكرت مصادر
العربيه بان زعيم طالبان يرغب باقاله رئيس
الاستخبارات عبد الحق وثيقه وتعيين احد
القندهاريين حتى يتمكن من الوصول الى كافه
ملفات الاستخبارات في الحكومه السابقه او
الحاليه الا ان جناح وزير الداخليه سراج
الدين حقاني يرفض ذلك ويتمسك ببقاء وثيق
في منصبه ويرفض اي سلطه اضافيه لقندهار
ونبقى معكم ولدينا في اخبار الساعه
الامم المتحده تعترف فشلنا في دعم
السوريين بعد الزلزال ونظام الاسد هو
المسؤول
[موسيقى]
في خطوه اعتبرت لمواجهه زياده النفوس
الصينيه في المحيطين الهند والهادئ بدا
اجتماع ثلاثي جمع قضت الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا واستراليا هدف لوضع لمسات اخيره
على صفقه الغواصات النوويه التي تنمي
كمبرا الحصول عليها ضمن التحالف الامنيه
المعروف حيث صرح مسؤول امريكي ان استراليا
تنمي شراء ثلاثه غواصات نوويه من واشنطن
وتدرس شراء اثنتين اخرتين فيما قال البيت
الابيض ان الولايات المتحده واستراليا
وبريطانيا ستتعاون لبناء جيل جديد من
الغواصات العامله بدفع النووي تهدف الدول
الثلاث لتبادل المعلومات الاستثمارات
الاستخباراتيه فضلا عن تزويد استراليا
بصواريخ كما تامل دول ثلاث تعاون في مجال
الصواريخ الفرد الصوتيه وذكاء الاصطناعي
والحرب الالكترونيه
ومن واشنطن ينضم الينا الزميل بيير غانم
مراسل العربيه مرحبا بك بيير الاعلان
والاخبار تشير الى ان التعاون بين الدول
الثلاث سيكون موسعا للغايه وليست صفقات
محدوده هل هذا ما يمكن فهمه بالطبع
قبل قليل بيان رسمي عن الدول الثلاث واكد
التفاصيل التي ذكرتها قبل قليل حول مشروع
الغواصات ما هو وراء مشروع الغواصات هو
مساعده امريكيه بريطانيه لاستراليا
لكي تنمي الاسطول البحري الذي لديها وتنمي
ايضا الصناعات العسكريه وبالتالي هذا
الحلف وسوف يكون على مدى بعيد جدا كما قال
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سولفان
قبل قليل انه اتفاق على مدى قرن وهذا
الاتفاق سوف يساعد استراليا لتقوم قوه
عسكريه جديده بمساعده البريطانيين
والامريكيين
السياسيه الامريكيه الهدف منهم
سعى المسؤولون في البيت الابيض للقول ان
هذا التحالف ليس موجها ضد احد ولكن اي شخص
في الاداره الامريكيه او خارج الاداره
الامريكيه يقول اولا ان هذا التحالف هو
بين ثلاث دول تتحدث اللغه الانجليزيه
ثانيا هذا التحالف موجه ضد الصين لماذا
لان الصين تحاول ان تتوسع في منطقه المحيط
الهادئ والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تفهم
ان هناك خطر واضح هو الخطر الصيني وتريد
ان تواجه هذا الخطر وعملت اداره بايدن منذ
الاسابيع الاولى من وصول الرئيس في العام
2021 الى البيت الابيض الى ايجاد تحالفات
جديده وهذا التحالف لمواجهه الصين بني
بمشاركه بريطانيا لمساعده استراليا
ومواجهه الصين في المحيط الهادئ طيب هذا
التحالف تحديدا كان قد اثار حفيظه عدد من
حلفاء الولايات المتحده ابرزهم فرنسا كيف
تعاملت الاداره الامريكيه في الاعلان عن
هذه الصفقات الجديده مع استراليا هل كان
هناك نوع من الحذر هل كان هناك نوع من
التوضيح بالبيانات لاهداف هذا التحالف او
التقليل من اهميته فيما يتعلق بالحلفاء
حقيقه ما حصل هو ان استراليا كان لديها
اتفاق لشراء غواصات من فرنسا وعند الاعلان
عن هذا الاتفاق الجديد بين بريطانيا
واستراليا وولايات المتحده الامريكيه تسبب
الامر بازمه نسميها ازمه دبلوماسيه بين
الفرنسيين والامريكيين واعتبر الفرنسيون
ان ذلك هو طعنه في ظهرهم وقد عمل الرئيس
بيضا لفتره طويله خلال عام 2021 لتخطي هذه
الازمه والان نرى ان الرئيس مكرون
والحكومه الفرنسيه قد تخطوا هذه المساله
على الرغم من انهم لا يستسيغونها كثيرا
وشعروا ان المتحدثون باللغه الانجليزيه قد
ابعدوا الفرنسيه عن هذه الصفقه
يحظى هذا التحالف الجديد بقبول من جناحي
السياسه في امريكا الحزب الجمهوري
والديمقراطي مع الديمقراطيه بالطبع
باعتبار ان اداره بيض تخوض في هذا التحالف
منذ فتره ماذا عن رده فعل الجمهوريين
يعتبر الحزبان ان الصين هي خطر متلاحق وان
على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تواجه
هذا الخطر الصيني
حرص الرئيس الامريكي على القول على ان هذا
الاتفاق الجديد ليس مدفوع من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بل ان المتلقي اي
اسراليا سوف تدفع ثمن الغواصات وسوف تشارك
في ذلك ايضا الحكومه البريطانيه وبالتالي
هو تحالف لمصلحه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكن ليس من جيوب دافعي الضرائب
الامريكيه نعم من واشنطن زميل بير غانم
مراسل العربيه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
ان معظم الضحايا في سوريا لم يتلقوا اي
دعم في اشاره الى الفشل في تقديم الدعم
الدولي في حاله الطوارئ وهو ما جعل
السوريين يشعرون بخيبه امل
لقد فشلوا في تسهيل ايصال المساعدات كانت
هناك مناقشات واجتماعات خلال سبعه ايام
ولم يتلقى معظم الضحايا اي دعم لقد فشلوا
في تقديم الدعم الدولي في حالات الطوارئ
بما في ذلك الفرق التي تم انقاذها
والمعدات في الاسبوع الاول الحيوي بعد
الزلزال شعر السوريون بالتخلي والاهمال من
قبل اولئك الذين يفترض بهم حمايتهم في اشد
حالات الياس في عصرهم
[موسيقى]
والان نذهب مشاهدينا الى كاليفورنيا
لمتابعه كلمه رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن خلال
لقائه برئيس الوزراء البريطاني ورئيس
الوزراء الاسترالي
من اجل بنائي ودعم هذه القوارم وبالمناسبه
هذه الشراكه
سوف تفضي في نهايه الامر بخلقه وظائف فتدر
اموالا جيده بالنسبه لنقابات عماليه كثيره
ولهذا السبب فاننا عملنا على بناء تلك
الغواصات وهي تتطلب تكنولوجيا متطوره
وسنوات مطوله من التدريب لذا فاننا سوف
نبدا على الفور وفي مطلع هذا العام فان
الضباطا من استراليا سوف يعملون على تدريب
على تلك الغواصات وكذلك ايضا سوف نعمل على
زياده الدعم الفني
في مجال الطاقه النوويه التي قد تحتاجها
تلك الغواصات وهذا سوف يطبق وفي نهايه هذا
العقد سوف نعمل على تاسيس وجود
بالتناوب بين استراليا وبريطانيا
والولايات المتحده والضمان كل ما تحتاجه
استراليا لبناء اسطول متطور هذه السفن
التي ترونها من خلفه هي هي من طراز بازار
من الغواصات الامريكيه التي تعد في في
طليعه
الغواصات واعذروني على هذا الامتياز التي
امنحه للولايات المتحده فهذه الغواصات
تحتل مكانه رائده
وكانت قد تم انتاجها في في ولايه ديلور
وكان لها دور متميز
فهي تمثل طليعه التكنولوجيا وتقدم قدره
على المناوره لا يمكن مضاهده
وبالنسبه للكونجرس فان الولايات المتحده
سوف تعمل على ثلاثه غواصات الى استراليا
مع قدره بيع اثنتين اخرتين اذا لزم الامر
بنفس القدرات
وهذا كان الهدف الاساسي لكن
الهدف من هذا البيع هو ان نعمل سويا او
معا من خلال هذا الاتفاق اتفاق اوكس الذي
يتم من خلاله تعزيز الغواصات النوويه التي
سوف تشكل تكاملا ما بين الولايات المتحده
والمملكه المتحده مع استراليا واود ان
اكرر هنا مجددا ان
ان اتفاق اوكسل لن يحمل في طياته اي سلاح
نووي بل سوف يكون صفته الاساسيه هو
التعاون بين البحريه الامريكيه
والاسرائيليه للوفاء بمتطلبات الدفاع في
استراليا والعمل من قبل العلماء
والمهندسين وكل
بلداننا اكثر قربا من اي وقت مضى دعوني
اشدد مره اخرى ان ان كافه الجوانب النوويه
قد تم اختبارها وهي امنه وقد مر على
استخدامها سنوات طويله وهي تحمل سجلا
حافلا ونظيفا في انجازها وقد استجابه
الكره الارضيه في
وقامت باكثر من مئه بقطع اكثر من 150
مليون ميل بحري لا يمكننا ان ننسى هذه
القدرات التي تمتلكها تلك الغواصات ولابد
لي ان اعترف ان هذه
ان هذه التكنولوجيا التكنولوجيه المحركات
التي تعمل بالدفع
قد تم
قد كان للادمر الفرانكلين الموجود معنا
الفضل في ادخال افكار لتطويرها بعد سنوات
طويله من التدريب سوف نض من بان استراليا
سوف تكون على استعداد
للوفاء بكافه المتطلبات الضروريه لسلامه
تلك السفن
وهذا التعاون قد يكون شهاده
لا غبار عليها حول التزامنا المشترك
لضماني ان امني منطقه المحيط الهادئ
وسلامته وسوف يخلق بالتالي فرصه لخلق
مستقبل
يهتدي بمبادئنا المشتركه في المملكه
المتحده واستراليا وفضلا عن الصداقه التي
تجمعنا في الاسيان وفي كافه المنتديات
الاخرى
العامه
هي هي من الاهداف الاساسيه الكبرى التي
تعمل على تحقيق الاستقرار في منطقه المحيط
الهادئ وسوف تغير من الديناميات
الاستراتيجيه وهذا المشروع الاول قد انطلق
للتو وهناك المزيد من الشراكات وترتيبات
امنيه اخرى سوف ترى النور
ولكننا سوف نعمل على وضعها في افضل مك انه
وقويه من اجل العمل سويا
لذا اود ان اشكر رئيس الوزراء البانيز
والرئيس الوزراء هناك والولايات المتحده
محظوظه بوجود صديقين مميزين يعملان على
خلق مستقبل افضل وامن للعالم في كل مكان
انني فخور بصداقتكما
الرئيس بايدن رئيس الوزراء سوناك انه
لشرف كبير ان اقف الى جانبكما هنا في
منطقه
المحيط الهادئ كاصدقاء يمكن الثقه بهم في
بلد استراليا اليوم صفحه جديده من
العلاقات بين دولنا يتم افتتاحها بين
الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده هذه
صداقه التي بنيت على قيمنا المشتركه
والتزامقراطيه والرؤيه المشتركه لتحقيق
مستقبل امن ومزدهر ان
اتفاقس الذي نؤكد عليه في سانديا قد يكون
اكبر استثمار في قدرات استراليا الدفاعيه
في تاريخنا برمته وهذا سوف يعزز الامن
القومي لاستراليا واستقرارنا وسوف يعمل
على بناء مستقبل يتم صنعه في من خلال
استثمارات كبيره ووظائف في البنى التحتيه
وتقديم قدره دفاعيه
كبيره في المستقبل ان حكومتي عازمه على
على الاستثمار في القدرات الدفاعيه وكذلك
اننا عازمون على تعزيز الامن من خلال
الاستثمار في علاقاتنا في جميع المناطق
وفي مطلع العقد المقبل سوف تتخذ استراليا
خطوات من اجل شراء ثلاثه
غواصات من الطراز الاول وهذه المره الاولى
التي نحصل على مثل هذه المناسبه منذ 65
عام بحيث تشاركنا الان الولايات المتحده
التقنيه هذه الغواصات التي تعمل بتقنيه
الدفع اننا نشعر ايضا بالفخر بشراكتنا مع
المملكه المتحده لانشاء الجيل الثاني من
الغواصات التي تسمى وهي
المسلحه بصوره تقليديه
وتعمل بالطاقه النوويه وتحم وتحمل في
طياتها طليعه تكنولوجيه برياده الولايات
المتحده والمملكه المتحده واستراليا هذه
سوف تكون قدرات سياديه استراليه بنيت من
قبل استراليا وسوف يتم قيادتها من قبل
البحريه الاسرائيليه وسوف يتم العمل على
تركيبها وتجميعها في صحه
ومناطق اسراليه ان استراليا لديها سجل
يدعو للفخر في مجال منع الانتشار النووي
وسوف نعمل على اتخاذ نفس هذا المسار وسوف
نفي بكافه التزامات التزاماتنا التي نصت
عليها اتفاقيه عدم الانتشار النووي
وكما نصت عليه نص عليه البيان النهائي
فيراري وسوف نعمل من خلال هذا التوجه على
زياده عمل
والارتكار في ادله وفينس وبرلد وفي غرب
استراليا وهنا في الولايات المتحده فرص
سوف يتم خلقها وتعزيزها
وتقويه اقتصاد استراليا لعقود من الزمن
وخلق ما يصل الى عشرين الف وظيفه مباشره
الى استراليا من تخصصات مختلفه في مجال
الهندسه والعلوم والمجالات الفنيه ومجال
ومجالات المتعلقه بالغواصات وظائف جيده
باجور
مغريه الامر الذي سوف يدفع الازدهار
بلادنا وعالمنا قاطبا ان مستقبلنا ان امن
مستقبلنا لا يعتمد فقط على شجاعه
وبساله القوات العسكريه بل ايضا تعتمد على
المعرفه الفنيه وعلى الفنيين
والعاملين في مجالات مختلفه مثل وبالنسبه
لاستراليا فانها بذلك تقدم فرص من خلال
هذه المبادره سوف يكون لدينا فرصه كبيره
سوف نعمل على تحقيق هذا الامر مع حكومتي
غربي اسره اليوم وشمال يسرا من اجل تطوير
التدريب وملئ تلك الوظائف من خلال هذا
العمل المشترك ومن خلال الجامعات ومعاهد
البحوث سوف نتعاون على تدريب المزيد من
الاستراليين حول الهندسه النوويه وكنا
نشاطر هذه المهارات والخبرات عبر حدودنا
مما يزيد من قدراتنا وخبراتنا في الدول
الثلاث
وسلفا وحتى هذا اليوم فان اسره تعمل على
زياده قدرات التكنولوجيا النوويه بالتعاون
مع
اقرانها في الولايات المتحده والمملكه
المتحده واليوم هناك بعض
المتدربين في مج الاسره في الولايات
المتحده
وهم يقول لك الرئيس بايدن انهم من طليعه
الطلبه في صفوفهم من خلال هذه التكنولوجيا
فان تلك القوارب سوف تقدم فرصه فريده من
نوعها للشركات الاسره لكي تساهم ليس فقط
في بناء
غواصه استراليه جديده بل سلسله سلسله
امدادات في استراليا وبريطانيا ان النطاق
ومدى التعقيد المتعلق بهذه الاستثمارات
سوف يكون حجر الاساس للارتكار في استراليا
والذي نراه للمره الاولى منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وكما ذلك وكما ذكر سلفي
في رئاسه الوزراء من شان هذا الامر ان
يرفع من وتيره قطاع تصنيع وسوف يكون هذا
الامر حافزا للباحثين
وسوف يعمل على دفع عجله الاقتصاد
الاسرائيلي وفي كل ولايه ومنطقه في
استراليا ليس فقط من خلال تصميم واحد وليس
في مجال واحد بل في كافه المجالات فان
تطور القطاع القطاعات التصنيعيه سوف تفضي
في خلق وظائف وزياده اعمال الشركات
وابتكارات مجزيه وسوف تدفع الشباب في
استراليا الى
اعتناق هذه الفرص التي تتاح هنا هذا ليس
فقط من خلال الخبرات المشتركه مع المملكه
المتحده ونثمن
طبعا هذا الاجماع الثلاثيه الامريكيه
البريطانيه الاستراليه بشان الغواصات
انانيه التي ستقوم امريكا ببيعها الى
استراليا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]